when you were in the nfl bro when you
first got drafted
concussions weren't a thing i'm sure you
know taking as many shots to get you out
on the field was very
normalized putting you on as many
painkillers was very normalized there
wasn't we weren't as aware of
you know the addictive effects of all
these things and
weed to me is like the anti-inflammatory
that's like
you know for any sport but really for
football
it should be pushed to the players i
mean that
that's that's what i believe from my own
experience of being an nfl player
not just playing myself but also being
around other guys and seeing what
happens to the guys
that you know they live off taking shots
and drinking beer with their vicodin
that's their their pain regimen and we
know what that does to people over
a long period of time or people that
aren't we used to have to take these uh
like indecent is what they are calling
and we used to have to take them the
night before before practice
yeah because if you didn't take it you
know you went out to practice and you
felt like you were 85 years old
but if you it's called innocent innocent
it's an insane it's like just a really
strong ibuprofen
and if you and if we took it i mean if
you didn't take it
you feel like 85 if you took you feel
like you're 12 years old was this
something that was
uh is still around yeah they they i mean
they give it out so
it's it's standard when you get into the
nfl the first time you know about
medicine yeah you get the everybody know
or the toradol shot
right everybody in the nfl knows about
this because it's a lifesaver
and and that's what that's what was the
norm and for me i remember one day i was
sitting in the training room and i was
seeing guys come in
one by one to get their tour doll shot
and i was thinking
if we're doing this for our whole
careers we're having to get shots what
is this going to do to our bodies
and then i kind of took a challenge on
to myself i said i want to see how long
i can go in the season
without without having to do that and
and i started smoking a little bit and i
was in the drug program so i had to like
measure it out you know i could take two
hits
the night you know the day after i got
tested and still be fine
and so i found that that worked i did a
little extra stretching
um you know just was more in touch with
my body and i didn't have to take those
those medicines
so i i learned from myself that cannabis
was better for me than
how long did you did you go the whole
year without having to take one of those
i had to take i had to take one
the second to last game of the season
but that was it what year was that
this was 2000 and uh this this 2003
when i led the nfl in cary's i carried
them almost 400 times